تكاد لا تخلو نشره اخبار من اسمه قصف
مدفعي وهجوم مسلح وفرار لمحكومين بالاعدام
انه السجن القومي بمدينه الخرطوم بحري
المعروف بسجن كوبر اقدم السجون في السودان
شيد في زمن الاستعمار الانجليزي عام
1903 سمي نسبه للجنرال الانجليزي كوبر
الذي تولى مهام ادارته يمتد السجن على
مساحه 5000 متر مربع ويضم 14 قسما منها
قسم لاصحاب احكام الاعدام واخر للمعتقلين
السياسيين وهو الاكثر شهره حيث يضم ابرز
قاده النظام السوداني السابق وعلى راسهم
الرئيس المعزول عمر البشير بعض وسائل
الاعلام المحليه قالت ان البشير هرب من
السجن في مقاله اخرى انه لا يتواجد في
زنزانته منذ فتره حيث يتلقى العلاج في احد
المشافي العسكريه فيما افادت مصادر ان
السجناء السياسيين لم يكونوا من ضمن من
خرجوا من السجن
[موسيقى]